we just thought it was you know it's
collapsed in the end it's changed our
problem we didn't realize know what was
going on so we've told to get off the
quick pictures quick as possible
maybe a barrier collapsed so we got the
dressing room and Kenny just said just
keep yourself warmed up we're going back
on him you know then the longer it went
you know the more realized that
something good had gone up
we had people crying outside the
changing room and shouting about you
know people dying out there there and
that's when it dawned on us obviously
then we told to get ready the Magisters
postponed
um we knew people have died and couldn't
get our heads around it and then when we
went up to the Sheffield
Wednesday's plays lounge the telly was
on and all our wives are there in tears
and and I remember John John Watson was
coming on and they're soaked
20:30 had died and I'm just coming
couldn't come to terms with it just
couldn't it was ridiculous you thought
it was a dream type of thing yeah we
possibly should have got counseled we
were counseling people as well which was
the right thing to do you know Kenny was
brilliant what we had to do and go to
the go to the every every funeral you
know brothers sisters son and dad and
yes always there is really tough